while starting today and for the rest of
the week we take you to Anaheim
California I spent a few days in
Southern California thanks to visit
Anaheim the sponsors of the segment so
first up here's a look at the beautiful
JW Marriott where we stayed on our trip
well if you make the trip from Vegas to
Anaheim you have to add the JW Marriott
to your list of where to stay it's the
only JW Marriott in Orange County I'm
joined by the director of sales and
marketing Mary Bell dinner thank you so
much for having us thank you we are in
the beautiful gardens and we're going to
talk about that in a little bit but I
say we go check out the property
just a short 10-minute walk from
Disneyland you will find yourself
immersed in luxury JW is the first JW
here in Orange County we're also the
first luxury hotel outside of the Disney
campus and we're very proud of that and
with a variety of rooms for every family
size the hotel is about 466 rooms we
have two presidential Suites so this is
one of them it's about 1800 square feet
and it has the master bathroom bedroom
that actually overlooks a Disneyland as
well which is amazing a place to relax
and recharge our hotel really is all
about family right so I know there's a
kind of demand people want to spend time
with their family especially with
Disneyland we are a short walk to
Disneyland there is a secret a pathway
to get there so about eight to ten
minutes and you're there the good thing
about it is you know you're not in the
hustle bustle of things so when you come
back to the hotel you can probably you
can feel recharged so we've made our way
to a different part of the property and
fun fact this chandelier behind me has a
tie into Las Vegas that I'm so excited
to tell you about so Mary Bell Tell me
about the chandelier yes so this is
actually inspired by the chandelier bar
at the Cosmopolitan in Vegas we
certainly don't want to be Vegas with
just the Allure of being in a vegas-like
property so it's kind of fun you know to
be able to go into a hotel that is
um you know very elegant but then like
you have this like Pizzazz and that
Pizzazz continues from the entrance to
the top level the check-in desk is
placed upstairs rather than on the first
level when you come in and from the
hustle bustle up everywhere wherever you
came from either from the airport or
from Disneyland you walk into a hotel
and feel the warmth and Tranquility of
it versus seeing like people lining up
to check in or to check out and once you
check in you can check out all the
amenities like a Wellness Center valet
parking with one-of-a-kind sculptures
and of course a pool the pool is amazing
it actually has a pool bar so it is an
extension of our bar area it has three
Cabanas with 55-inch TV monitor we do
Cabana service you've got David's as
well and so it's just a fun place for
people to relax after a long day to help
a little bit about the Rooftop Bar it's
the views up there alone are worth it
yeah so it's Parker Street Rooftop Bar
it is the highest rooftop bar in Anaheim
second highs in Orange County it has an
amazing view of Disneyland so you get to
see fireworks when Disneyland has the
fireworks on and also you have the
amazing California sunset views it's
really spectacular up there overlooking
the fireworks and overlooking the
beautiful gardens we call it a secret
garden because you don't expect that
Garden to exist in Anaheim it divides
into four quadrants so we do have a
succulent section that has a butterfly
wall that people can take instagramable
moments in all of the Butterflies were
made specifically for us by a local
artists in Laguna plus there is a Floral
Garden an Edible Garden that is used for
fresh ingredients audience in their
on-site restaurant tocophera and an
augmented reality experience you as a
guest or a downloadable phone
application can plant your seed of your
imagination and then go through the
different installations that we have and
eventually lead you to this Pitbull
portal where you enter a digital forest
and see the tree that you planted a
place to plant your roots and a place to
call a home away from home this is kind
of like the epicenter I would say of
where they want to plant themselves when
they travel to Anna especially those
from Vegas because you can drive it from
Vegas to here